now this is a binomial okay it's a
binomial because by 2 means 2 and only
means it's when this context that means
terms okay so this topic is also
sometimes called binomial expansions now
what they do is they take binomials like
this and we raise them to different
powers and we expand them and we see
what happens okay now if you're like me
you're kind of like what does this have
to do with anything this is like the
worst segue in all history okay so stay
with me this is a pretty simple one
right parent what nothing happens okay
but when you raise the powers being
start to get a bit interesting okay for
starters yeah I know you know what this
expansion is but I'm gonna write it like
this for a second
I'm gonna do it in for long hair that
takes I'm going to try and make the
connection between algebra and
arrangements okay now if I actually take
each term and I think about order right
so I'm gonna go a times a then a times B
then V times a then B totally okay now
at four combinations here okay four
different ways of doing this at four
comes from its two to the power two see
why that's important in a second okay
all right now when you put that together
you get this result just quite familiar
okay but calf is too it's really
important okay we'll come back into into
a second let's do the next one up okay
again I'm gonna expand it out long range
okay so I'm going to get a plus B times
this guy right which is actually this
okay you wondering why I'm making you do
all these extra writing just stay with
us okay let's write all out this time
we're going to get it eh-eh-eh-eh-eh be
baby okay and again but we could be on
the front okay now how many terms are
there you there are eight terms namely
two cute can you see why it's too cute
think Amanda is an arrangement question
can you see why this is two cubed
because I'm now trying to think of three
different things we're going to fill
three boxes every term that I get after
you has three turns right three bits and
then each time I've got two options for
how to fill them right that's two Q's
right that's why they're atm okay
all right let's combine all together so
I get a cubed now the way we write this
in out by clicking like terms we don't
really care about order mmm
notice that okay so we're actually
turning into an NPR to an NCR okay watch
that this is the same as this which is
the same as it's okay so I've got three
a squared B this is the same as this is
the same as this okay so I also have
three all right now look at these
numbers with me these are the important
ones okay I'm going to do one more
because I'm gonna stop running out of
room to look at that and then I wonder
if you
a plus B it's anaphor okay I'm going to
actually just write out what what the
expansion is okay because I already know
when these it's going to be okay
now I know you'll probably recognize
these numbers from Pascal triangle
hopefully and u7 if we taught you
anything but what does it have to do
with or the arrangements you're talking
about and it's two letter business okay
well think about these numbers okay
this question here asking this question
how many of these do I have or you know
how many of these do I have is really
like saying okay
how many permutations are there so this
one lines up with these underlined ones
okay where I've got to come up with a
three-letter word right and two of the
letters I repeated okay
and then the other one is the left over
okay so how many ways is that we just
established that was about NCR right so
I'm trying to call with a three letter
word and I've got how many repeats well
got this um this double head okay so
that's 3 factorial 1 factorial the one
corresponds to the beat okay that's 3
choose 2 okay you see that this comes
from the repeat okay
in the same way actually should write
this as 3 choose 1 that's the proper way
this way over here because of the
symmetry of it is 3 choose 2 that's why
it's the same number okay we established
that these are actually the same come up
here okay what's this one this is how
many ways can I make a four letter word
and I've got an A
abb that's what I got to play with okay
so it's a four-letter word and I'm
dividing by that 3 factorial 1 factorial
okay that's 4 choose 1 or 4 choose 3
they're the same okay about this one in
the middle yeah oh yes I so much to say
4 I've got I've got 4 different spots to
feel yeah now just what I've got A's and
B's right all of the ones that look like
this a b a b ba ba and so on okay they
all run together I've got to come with a
four letter word right and there's a
double up of a's there's a double up of
bees right
that's 4 choose 2 now that's kind of
interesting isn't it
does it work all the way to the ends
there's a 1 here and a 1 here right just
work let's think about it the pattern
goes 1 2 3 if I've got to make a 4 than
a word right and they're all repeated B
how many ways are there of combining
them answer what right and if I've got
sorry part it's fun over here okay
what's this correspond to 4 factorial
odd now it's actually the same isn't it
it's the same as this guy over here
right but I'm actually thinking about as
rather than 4 factorial 0 factorial I
think that the other way around this is
4 choose 0 okay so another way of saying
that the way you used to say that is
I've got 4 and I don't want to pick any
of them because y'all suck so there's
only one way to pick none of you which
is to pick none of you okay so what
you've got is these guys appearing right
which by the way if you can't remember
that's the way a faster way of writing
NCR right
okay sir can we generalize it if I have
some kind of binomial expansion right
raise it to any power you like as long
as it's an integer okay what I'm
interested in is these numbers here of
course you can build them off using
Pascal's triangle but the problem with
that is for instance if I want this to
be able to be 220 okay that means I've
got to build the first 19 rows which
will take forever
okay I can go directly there if I use
these things okay so where do these
numbers come from okay my first
coefficient well it's always got four at
the top that came from here right
whatever power I'm raising to so it's n
choose now the first one and choose zero
okay and the first expansion which is
just a to the whatever power your reason
to okay now when you move along you're
going to go the same number choose iPod
right and because you've gone along
another term this power is going to
reduce but this one's going to increase
and it keeps going this will be n minus
2 this will be 2 now because I raise it
to the power n if I raise it to the
power 4 I'll get 5 terms and raise it to
the power of 3 I get four terms here
actually expect to have n plus 1 terms
right so this will add all the way up
until now what's the last couple of
terms right well for choose 3 so that's
n choose just one less than him right
and we're a muck 2 is just one a left
over and I've almost got all the B's and
the very last one is in shoes which
again is just 1 so you have this
symmetry happening here okay
so I wonder how well I do if you can see
why algebra is actually about
arrangements right it's about trying to
work out well how many of these
connected together that's where that 4
comes from or the 6 or the 5 or the 10
or 20 or whatever okay